you're talking about like drinking a lot
of water what about energy drink because
I drink no what are you [ __ ] talking
about
you're joking right everybody it's gary
vaynerchuck I'm doing something a little
bit different with this askgaryvee we're
gonna mainly just do a 5 to 7 set up cuz
Hannah's been on the show before in a
pod sessions so I know some of the
audience knows her and you can just
google that you know pod sessions with
Hannah Brockman but uh I want to let her
set up this incredible book that's
causing a bunch of buzz to talk to us
about what it is a little bit and then
really what I want to do what I really
want to do is is really allow you guys
to have access the more I think about
the world I always think about content
but access to me is a really big part of
in so actually getting to ask Hannah
some questions
oh the nails are on fire I think you get
them you got the words see you know what
this might be the first time ever I wish
I had nails because I just like the fact
that you can like put words on them I
want to make sure that you guys get some
access and so why don't you tell the
vaynernation everybody watching on
streams and on the Internet's what this
books about and how it became to be yeah
sure okay so I've been in the wellness
world now for the last ten years and
started from a night I was DJing
nightlife and I kind of woke up one
morning and I was just completely burnt
out and I just really you know I felt
like [ __ ] my skin was terrible my like I
was eating once a day I was drinking a
ton and I was basically up all night and
sleeping all day and so I kind of just
said to myself this lifestyle is not
sustainable at all how long do you do
that lifestyle for um for about three
years that was really hard
yeah and that was right after college so
I mean you're also more ready on college
to be yeah exactly counting those
college years to and actually when I was
in college something pretty insane well
it was you
no my grandmother passed away and she
actually had suffered from anorexia her
whole life and when I was with her and
she passed away it was one of those
moments where I just kind of said to
myself I I know I should devote myself
to living the happiest and healthiest
version of myself because that was
something that she never did and so
desperately I think wanted for her
grandkids and so between that happening
and then waking up one day and feeling
like absolute crap I basically decided
that there needed to be a huge overhaul
in my lifestyle and that I needed to
take my health seriously and even at
that young age yeah it was about 22
years old
and I just I noticed that I had gotten
away from all the things that really
made you at college at 19 325 because it
was three years after college
no I guess oh yeah I guess you're right
I guess that's around 24 and I graduated
college at 21 and it was just one of
those moments where I I behaved very
good and intense listen I wrote over
here um and so it was just didn't think
I could one of those things where I
realized that I had done so much damage
to myself so that's when I really kind
of like just got on the health journey I
started exploring different experts
trying to figure out what was going on
with me
why was food making me feel so shitty
how to take care of myself and I kind of
grew up the very active back like as a
kid I was a dancer I played sports I
loved cooking and I just wanted to get
back to the things that really made me
feel great and so I started meeting with
all these amazing doctors taking all
these tests trying all these different
diets I ended up starting my first
startup in the beauty world kind of
launched my like beauty curiosity and it
kind of put me as like an expert in the
beauty world and so over the last ten
years I've really amassed all this crazy
info regarding health beauty and fitness
and wellness overall and well-being and
mindfulness so this book is really a
download of everything I've learned over
the 10 years I think we can all
understand that wellness has become such
a crowded space yeah I was I was just
about to ask you you know as you were
Hakan was like okay the follow-up here
is so much has happened when you first
started flirting with it you know just
if you just even think about instagrams
growth and the permission for anybody to
go into the space and whatever their
interpretation it is like what's your
take on that my take is that basically
any it make the it makes it accessible
for anyone and everyone to have an
opinion on what works what doesn't work
and a lot of this can be like fake news
false advertisements a lot of
misinformation yeah exactly and it can
also lead the customer or their viewer
to have a really hard time of knowing
where the entry point is and
understanding what's the one thing that
they want to try or what you know and
trying to also figure out what's not a
fad and what's actually gonna make a
difference in their life so I've tried
all the fads because I'm a huge guinea
pig and that's what I love to do and I'd
love to be ahead of trends hence me
being on this journeys you know for the
last ten years and it really coming to
popularity I think in the last five but
yeah so this book has like a ton of
accessible ways of entering in the
wellness world because I feel like you
know media has really made wellness feel
like a very inaccessible boutique
fitness organic food like white bland
scene and that's really not the case at
all and everyone you know I mean there's
some like like I'm just thinking about a
couple grandmas I know we're like just
diehard like no it's just dub soap right
like you know like like 93 year old
grandmas you're like oh my god like oh
just stuff so for the last 63 years like
I feel like you need to figure it out
for yourself
totally egg dub soap might have worked
for Gertrude it might suck for Calvin
right totally and I think you know one
of the one of the big things that I talk
about is how I learned to listen to my
body and what I'm hoping but people
really get from this book is a little
bit more understanding of themselves and
that I hope this book asks the right
questions to help you kind of figure out
what you're maybe not really being
truthful with yourself about and how you
can better understand yourself because I
think it's really true it
it really just saying what works for me
isn't gonna work for you one totally the
reason by far the thing that I hope most
people hear when I talk about business
and marketing is about self-awareness
right like which is what led me to
insecurity right I'm like oh people are
not willing to be themselves because
they're worried about judgment of others
I think a lot of that you know I'm
thinking about it quite a bit on like
mindset but I have so much empathy
especially for women around physical
appearance like that's tough like loving
yourself under complete like conditions
of the pressure of what judgment of
beauty or financial success or alpha
male or females like there's it's just a
lot totally I talk so much about the
mindset as well and it really
understanding that you know how to tune
out the haters like how to really focus
in and not compare yourself to other
people I mean there's so much out there
that like make it really difficult for
women to feel comfortable in their own
skin and a lot of what I talk about is
kind of body confidence and like my own
and like journey of identity as well
which I feel like people can relate to
where are you on your journey like
current state of the union of your life
going through this you know being public
in a lot of ways yeah having a little
bit of a girl status and all that like
where are you like right this minute
like you'll look back at this video in
three years and be like oh crap I was
kill it that my question is what are you
where are you best right now in your
historical journey like your best about
like you like your eyes for the first
time ever like like literally what right
the second where are you at the best and
what do you most continuously strut like
what are you most struggling with or
trying to hack or get better on and what
are you the best at in your own context
so right now I feel like where I'm where
I'm at right now is really for the first
time feeling 100% comfortable with
within my own skin like in my body I
feel like I am like you know heavier
than I was four years ago but I like
love my curves every inch of them I feel
like I'm stronger than I ever have been
and so I'm just feeling 100% about kind
of like my body goals and just
like being nots to say that I don't have
more like gym goals and whatever but
that I feel really confident like you're
just like this is this is me this is
like DNA this yeah and here's where the
margins are totally I'm not gonna be
like to me I've always that like to meet
guys and girls it's like look like I'm
like there's certain things that no
matter what you do aren't going to
happen it's a DNA game absolutely and I
feel like your delusion I've totally
figured out like my eating habits what
works for me I'm on top of them I'm what
wait for you eating just a ton of
vegetables and lean protein annals for
you yeah and it but I love that G is a
little bit I don't eat really processed
food not a lot of grains if I'm gonna
eat animal proteins it really needs to
be pasteurized and like wild-caught fish
what do you allow yourself to be a
guilty pleasure currently um I mean
chocolate is like but I don't even think
of it as a guilty pleasure like
chocolate is good for you well then I
love some dark chocolate like hide cacao
count I love two percent No okay yeah
you're right I don't know I don't eat
candy but I do love like my eighty two
percent but like but that's not guilty
like what is your like I'll eat like
some sour patch kids when nobody's
really looking I actually don't see this
is the people ask me this but I really
feel like I've trained myself to think
that like fruit is a guilty pleasure by
the way by the way in my best eating
habits which ran for like two and a half
years I'm off of it right now cuz I'm
more into muscle game which is giving me
room sure a little ridiculous yeah but I
know in six months me and Micah coming
back he's coming back in for six months
to like really get back to it like fruit
was like like fruit was like an enemy
yeah it was okay like their sugar like
yeah yeah like now I'm like ollie the
Twizzlers like I'll do some [ __ ] I mean
I guess like dirty nachos okay every
once in a while like yeah you know
around that shitty cheese on top of you
yeah like I yeah and I'm not even making
them myself like I will go out to like a
pub like warn somebody seven makes like
kind of the best nachos and I'm totally
here for that once in a bloomin
everybody watching on all the live
streams Instagram you guys to the
Facebook Twitter please put in your
phone number right now Calvin who's in
for Andy by the way the
the young crews here Andy Sid d-roc
they're all in India right now for SIDS
wedding big shout out to said
congratulations I guess he's gone for
like ever
like that's how he's rolling yeah I
think the other guys are back in a
couple weeks so the young crews in here
so Calvin's it for Andy putting your
phone numbers right now on the streams I
want to talk about health wellness
influencer marketing hannah has done a
great job building a bit please yeah I
was gonna say you've been so
instrumental I feel like with what I'm
my whole what I'm even doing with the
book and the promo and everything and
I'm so excited to tell you that I've
been on my Instagram ads and my facebook
ads and it's you're right it's so easy
and I don't know why I was even
hesitating it's similar to Fitness I can
tell everybody right now if they want to
get into way better shape and like be
happier sleep like listen to your body
and sleep more or what's appropriate to
what your body's doing hmm
eat growth like like stop eating fats
and sugar like hmm like and workout like
like it's like the formula is basic the
executions for some reason everything
that I Spit yeah you're referring to
after the last one of the times we hung
out yeah like when the cameras are off
I'm like listen to me yeah execute this
it will be you know you have something
different than most you have the fact
that you had organic success because of
who you are how you executed a lot of
people so like people who have organic
success don't do the ads and things that
nature because there's organic success
right other people just don't put in the
work there's a million reasons why but
it's funny like it makes me so happy
that you're doing it because it is a
moment in time totally like this will go
away right
like one day Instagram will be myspace I
can't even and that like seems so it's
terrifying well the reason it's
terrifying is you know what really
scares me is and you don't have this
problem even though interims so
important to you same for me 98% of
people watching right now if Instagram
broke and disappeared off the face off
the earth tomorrow they would disappear
off the face of the earth right so I
think you know if you're my quick little
PSA if you're watching right now is get
your Linkedin and your blog and your
email
and your text messaging platform and
your Twitter and your Facebook and your
podcast game up YouTube like why are you
one-dimensional right anyway you got a
phone let's do it
so the female last week the book came
out last week we Tuesday this is so
exciting then we're gonna call someone
who's the name Erica this is so cool I'm
like old school okay this is like
old-school like radial exports radio I
feel like I'm in an episode of Mervyn
your fella has been forwarding four zero
four six zero four nine nine three four
is not available at the tone please
record your message
when you have finished recording you may
hang out or press 1 for more options
Eric it's Gary Vee you [ __ ] up it's
also an approximant I was hoping we
could chat but I guess but we can't
because you [ __ ] up okay so yeah
alright we'll go to the next one so
Hanna the book came out Thursday Tuesday
last week same last week on Janna I know
it's always a giant oh I see the new
year new you okay so that's what you
guys per se which my who's a
HarperCollins Harper wave mine is
HarperCollins too by the way the whole
new year new you I mean I get it but for
me I always say there's no better time
to start something than today I agree I
mean like I'm like I didn't do it this
year but like three or four years in a
row I would make it like a New Year's
resolution video on like December 13th
and I'm like why are you waiting at 19
days yeah like right but for book
purposes totally a good time of year
yeah thanks makes you want it absolutely
Trent Trent Trent's gonna have something
hopefully tremble answer so we're gonna
go into have like for a lot of people
books are a big thing and I want to know
how the book one for you okay yeah we're
calling so Trent it was Gary be alright
it's alright it's Gary you got my
serious right now holy [ __ ] okay Trent
holy [ __ ] what's up dude what's up dude
you're on we don't know how long I've
been waiting for this [ __ ]
oh my god Trent where where are you from
I'm from Texas
what part Fort Worth love it
do you have a question for Hannah I do I
do
oh my god okay so big question for you
so I worked full time I build airplane
parts here in Fort Worth
I am a content creator and I'm trying to
get my health on track but I mean I
worked like 40 hours a week here and
then like another 20 doing my hustle how
do I fit it in well you're working part
time at 60 hours a week so you got
unlimited time to the first seven
minutes of when you wake up and how
that's supposed to really help
metabolism speed up so I would hold on
hold on oh I apologize cuz I was making
jokes like what do you say about for
seven minutes so within the first seven
minutes of waking up that's when your
that's like when your all your [ __ ] is
spiking so like you're gonna hit this is
no joke and you may not know like is
this like been like like stake in the
ground like tobacco causes cancer kind
of like or is that the current
hypothesis of culture no I mean I'm
asking I don't know no it's it's a it's
a real thing that Corozal I'm not sure
about trent specifically if you have
cortisol should if you're in healthy
shape spike in the morning and that's
what basically helps you metabolize and
burn calories all day long and so what
should one do in the first cell what's
in the first seven minutes I would say
get a 5 minute workout in which
literally means do one minute of jumping
Josh to one wall one minute of a wall
plank or a wall set rather which by the
way I apologize interrupt cuz I've been
being good on this episode but when I
first started working out for real 5
years ago the wall sit is hard
destroy I like yeah it's the only thing
that I click cried about see this [ __ ]
right yes yes not interrupting so you're
talking about hair right like a piece
yeah but not even but it also really
does mean like getting your heart weight
rate up in a really intense way and I'm
kind of also just talking about even
doing a wall sit which doesn't like
technically mean a lot of cardio it does
get your heart rate up so even doing
that and doing them in a minute of
sit-ups and you can do something
different every day one minute of
exercise with five different exercises
is five minutes right when you wake up
you can do it right
to your bed and that'll kind of set you
up for a better execution of your day I
mean it sounds like like I was just like
you know what I'm gonna wake up and now
I'm just gonna run out of my house like
like like in a dead like I was I was
sleeping eight seconds ago I'm gonna put
on shorts like I'm gonna wear shorts and
a t-shirt where I sleep now and just run
out to New York City is that okay
I'm also trying I'm not sure exactly
what your health goals are whether it's
like you know losing weight gaining
muscle like what's a scam that's what
scares Trent what's your goal with you
so my goals I want to I'm running 5k 10k
15k and then I have a Spartan Race in
June and then another one in October Wow
and so I'm I'm not like I'm trying to
I'm trying to push it to like the very
next level because everything I'm doing
right now so I just started give you
really hard to hide videography so I
closed the since you're 21 for like a
year contract so we're on course to do
40 kms here and so I'm just I can't
believe I'm talking y'all guys right now
I'm sorry I'm like no don't worry Trent
it's real this is not a dream so Trevor
you trying to win the New York Marathon
like where are we going with this I did
I just want to push my body to the next
level that and that's it like it's
nothing more than like you like it like
it's like um I love it I love it so I
I'm super competitive so I use the box
but I got knocked out by his name protip
never fight a kid named Mufasa he will
win yeah
like the kids name with Mufasa that was
his fighting name lamb down in your new
book is there like tricks to beat Mufasa
in a boxing match trendy it's well it's
very mental right if you're not focused
on what you're doing and being present
you're gonna get knocked out by Mufasa
yeah nobody wants to know nobody wants
that whatever you want to say in terms
of your goals of like the 5k and the
Spartan races and stuff like that like
obviously agility moves and and getting
your endurance up is gonna be something
that's gonna like really help you in
those particular types of
the cell block thing so I don't know if
your what you do on the weekends I mean
it sounds like you don't have that much
time but like if you go out to lasik
stuff like a Tough Mudder or just even
get one of those like ladder ropes and
and you're into content I mean you can
start if you have like a little tripod
or something you can start filming all
this stuff and it's like a trend but
Trent do you eat like [ __ ] tell the
truth do not lie to Hanna I'll be
straight with you I eat like garbage
yeah I knew it I felt it right through
the vocals you know it I know I could
tell that Mufasa knocked you out and you
were like this is nothing like this like
Trent's gonna like run all through
Dallas meanwhile eat like 40 I like like
no chocolate pause it's not that bad I
mean it's not that bad like I'm still
eating chicken or rice but yeah my
overall glad you ate some [ __ ]
chicken once you're eating dog [ __ ] and
unit rent do not lie to Hanna Trent do
you eat processed food a ton yeah do you
eat a lot of sugar yes yes how much
water do you drink a day not much I
could I kinda at least get a gallon in
that's a lot that's a lot I don't drink
water for [ __ ] I'm gonna dry up and
disappear you hated right well I
basically never drank water mother fell
in the water
yeah no he figured out heck it's like
the gallon that you give you know why he
drinks a lot of water I because exactly
I hit a bad job with my guess it's
cliche all these people walking around
my office but like look at my gallon and
then I look at their [ __ ] table and
they've got like Taco Bell and [ __ ]
Twizzlers everywhere right look people
love to do band-aids like yo I run a 5k
and I drink water
cool bro you ain't 43 Twinkies this week
right how many vegetables you do you eat
a day six I try to at least do a handful
of broccoli a day the like see see like
I'm still eating like crap but I'm doing
like a handful of veggies essentially
for like two meals so it doesn't really
do anything okay I was just okay so in
addition to like those agility and
endurance things that you're obviously
your water intake is great but you
clearly need to switch up what you're
eating and I would say try and eat a
majority of vegetables on your plate
with like you know
a six to eight ounce piece of protein
and cut out all of your processed [ __ ]
and then if you're hungry you should be
snacking on yeah a lot of people like
talk to me I watch games yeah I think
it's really important I beat you and
you're hungry I great otherwise you're
right you're gonna like I used to not
eat durian I still basically don't eat
Thor in a day but when when what would
happen is I would eat 7,000 calories at
like 10:00 p.m. yeah terrible don't you
should definitely not be eating at least
two and a half hours before you go to
bed because your body like really
digests and detoxes while you're
sleeping so definitely and you should be
drinking two glasses of water before you
go to bed and two glasses of water as
soon as you wake like no joke like like
this is like the cliche like I'm dying
to ask you this like straight up like
and don't lie to me like you're nailing
this to glass thing in the morning at
night
oh hell yeah seven days a week oh that
is not like religion to you oh my god
like just like taking [ __ ] I know crazy
did I do also I don't eat and drink at
the same time because for optimal
digestion you're supposed to drink water
45 minutes before and after a meal I
talk about it in my book honestly how
this stuff sounds too hard just like
jack-in-the-box honestly it's like small
conscious things that you should be
doing but I was gonna say about snacking
you should definitely be snacking on
veggies some like protein whether it's
like whether you're making eating like
carrots and hummus or even just like
some sliced turkey like just don't eat
how do you feel how do you feel about
flatbread like wheat flatbread no Panera
like what's happening there
dude you're like no like I'm about to go
to Carbone after this and I'm about to
eat so much spaghetti and just think
about how [ __ ] up this all is because
Hannah just told me not to do any of
this [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna have like 14
glasses of wine and like nine piece of
bread and like triple spaghetti specials
only [ __ ] Monday bro right but that I
won't eat Tuesday like I by the way
that's Tara you know this is worth
listening to your body's interesting and
I believe you and I do believe that
there are bet like I always like in
marketing there's best-case strategies
and then there's nuances I will tell you
as as
forty three-year-old no question I'm not
talking about gorging and then take away
gorging like when I'm eating properly a
my best when I'm eating properly
consistently and still having a fast day
really feels not I don't want a fast to
act cool or I think it's right it's
crazy how much my body reacts having a
fast day is very very good for you oh
god I believe it it's very I really it's
very weird for me like your organs need
to like have some rest time I believe it
mm-hmm
do you ever or yeah yeah well or random
randomly and I'll do a water day every
now and then I don't necessarily promote
it do you or talk about it on the
internet if he won't feel like you
slipped like is there like I've always
you know I actually end up doing it when
I've been really really good because I
find that when you're doing things in a
really consistent good manner your body
benefits even more when you have like a
detox day try thanks for calm bro yeah
so here wait wait super quick two things
so you're talking about like drinking a
lot of water what about energy drink
because I drink know what [ __ ]
talking about you're joking right no no
you're no more be no be good
okay so no more of that no no dude no
more that okay okay okay no I'm being
dead I could tell okay doyeong said
y'all wanna crush it but real quick I
mean flatbreads and Red Bull like do you
think I'm okay you think I'm good I
don't get differently oh god okay yeah
then other than that how much wine do I
have to buy to see we're just going bad
on the on the whole fitness thing here
how much wine do I have to buy to be
able to meet you in October because I'm
coming out to New York City me and my
fiance are coming out there to
experience New York like you know how
much honestly the real answer is way way
more than you want to hear because I
think me and rowdy have been bartering
it for like $10,000 worth of wine so
we're talking like 50 cases but your
energy is so good and I like you so send
me an email and let me see how I can
sneak you in for at least a minute dude
oh my god you're making
freaking life right now all right dude
I'm flattered we're talk soon all right
more calls Trent
oh no wait you know what's interesting
and I'm sitting there listening and he's
obviously excited nice kid
and like for a minute there I thought he
was joking I honestly believe he wasn't
like for if you actually like the bet
right now I don't think he was joking
and what's funny about that is no
different than like being over educated
in whether its wine or the New York Jets
or marketing you know like boy you
really thought like energy drink some
flatbread yeah it was also crazy to like
then hear how disconnected his goals are
from his like day to day rate he had
these big goals of being the Spartan
doing the Spartan Race says his like you
know whatever what the five K's and
whatnot get his daily are just like
saying the opposite and by the way it's
scary you can't outwork your mouth like
like I workout for real now and like
when you're not eating well
see ya hello hello it's Gary Vaynerchuk
with Hannah Brockman yeah okay alright I
promised my husband I would not freak
out so we're good olive where do you
know T where do you live I'm throwing on
the inside I love your name olive it's
so pretty thank you where do you win so
much said it again where do you live I'm
in Tampa Florida I just moved here from
from California my husband just retired
from the military so we're settled in
we're good to go thank you so much on a
service what can we answer for you okay
so here's what I'm doing right now I'm
already coaching I'm a health and
wellness coach I've done NPC composition
before that's not my route that's not
what I want to do I really want to get
back to like the holistic approach for
clients so I'm just trying to teach them
the same things as you Hannah like love
yourself make it take good care of
yourself and love that thank you but I
only started in November I know Gary
patients I got you but I need to work on
some products like supplement my income
in the mean time and so my client list
who is that real quick before you go
anywhere further cuz this is super
important for a lot of people a lot of
people try to build an audience and then
they want to monetize right the problem
is they try to monetize their audience
too soon and what ends up happening is
you never end up building an audio
because at 300 or 3000 or whatever it
may be you get into a place where you
went in for the sale before you romance
to your audience one of the reasons I
was able to become who I was was I was
building a wine business on the side so
for a deck even to this point I don't
monetize my audience the way most people
do and and I don't even care if people
buy wine or sneakers which is completely
left field from what I do there is you
know that that content 86 page deck I
put out that's normally the move for
somebody like me where you charge $3,000
for that ebook I would tell you the
number one and this is I'm so glad you
asked this olive because it gives me an
opportunity to deliver kind of my 2019
like thing that I thought of on the
beach which is if I could give one great
piece of advice to anybody if you're
building a health and wellness brand to
your audience before doing what
everybody tells you on the internet all
these internet marketers which is you
need an $89 product to monetize to them
which Tunes everybody out half the room
just roll their eyes because we all see
it I want you to monetize something that
has nothing to do with that side of your
life so that you could afford to
continue to organically build an
audience I believe that the reason I'm
so passionate about the flipped life and
selling and trading and buying
tchotchkes and dollar stores and garage
sales is you will be so much more
financially successful if you figure out
how to flip on the side and make four
thousand you know or three thousand or
two thousand dollars a month if you need
to subsidize because the second you
start selling a cliche affiliate powder
shake or detox this or you try to create
your own $239 you know open right now
pre sell at $99 you become one of them
which is 99 percent of what we see on
Instagram which is why 99 percent of
people don't win I can't even believe
that I first of all that was awesome and
I can't believe that I feel like I'm one
of those people I've just now for the
first time in seven or eight years put
out a product yes and I've already spent
this whole time the book yeah the book
being the product but this whole time I
really romanced my audience and try to
get them in love with like the types of
messaging and content that I put out
with and then you know only now
and you and I four different
circumstances and realities because we
built other businesses before could
afford not having to monetize our
audience right when I hear olive calling
and millions of emails and DMS that I
get a year from people that need to
monetize and have decided I'm going to
be a personal brand on this and I'm
gonna sell this thing I love my advice
and I'm not kidding it like really
dawned on me during vacation because you
get to think on a hammock and like
Mexican like I'm thinking I'm like wait
a minute if I put these two passions
together I can help people learn how to
buy and sell things like from garage
sales and I believe every woman that has
a fashion sense can dominate the
goodwill yes I really do yeah and I
actually think a lot of olive I actually
think you in Tampa from dollar stores
thrift stores or buying bulk and doing
retail arbitrage are more likely to make
$5,000 a month doing that and still have
time to build your fitness thing because
I'm telling you right now sister if you
come out with a dollar ninety-nine that
$200 item you're not going to build an
actual audience
I totally agree with you and Gary I'm
not even kidding you my flipping starts
next week
we love you wrapped up I'm not even
kidding I flipped a ton when we lived we
lived in Humboldt California you have
four years and I'm like great she's
humble fog baby Humboldt fog is about
yes but I don't eat it cause Hannah will
punch her oh I'm sorry go ahead
no I know it's terrible I know it's like
triple cream like like it's 47,000
calories in like one scoop on a Ritz
cracker but go ahead so good but I
totally agree with you and you know the
the four years that I lived in Humboldt
I was a trainer and nutrition coach so
currently my clients are still the ones
who have been with me since the
beginning I took a little time off I
went down another industry and I came
right back so I still have the clients
that I have right now are all ones that
have worked with me before so I'm not
hard up I'm mailing my list I put out
maybe one or two offers just for the
coaching yep but I haven't tried to sell
them for anything else and the
coaching is my mailing list is I would
say 98% people that have already worked
with before great so look the more
listen I had a call today with a real
estate company and they were asking why
real estate agents are struggling on
social and I'm like because they're
trying to sell a home on every post
right like that like still to this day I
think Jab Jab Jab right hook that book I
wrote impacted so many people because it
gave them a very simple way to think
about like give give give and then ask
right too many people interpreted it as
give give give and take mm-hmm when you
emanate X if if we can create something
in 2019 where you eliminate expectation
from your following like that's the part
that everybody's struggling with they
give they don't owe me
that's right that's exactly right but
everybody's like you know I've been put
out this great content like now by my
[ __ ] like have you been putting out
great content man wait have you been
putting out great content the whole time
just I mean it's literally guy and girl
dynamics I tell a lot of guys and or
girls on a one-to-one I'm like look it's
dating dynamics if you're such a nice
guy to the girl
mainly just to hook up one time like
you're not gonna win that you're not
gonna write something meaningful man you
have a short-term agenda right right and
so like why are you giving and what are
you trying to create so look if you have
the hustle of flipping and that can buy
you ear cover to disproportionally give
content and all your best advice which
then gives you the advantage on once a
year throwing that right hook for
whatever you're trying to do within that
fitness space you will win yeah you're
so right
yeah thank you I needed to hear that so
bad you don't understand how bad I
needed to hear that I you know what's
funny it took me a long time only
started tapping into these feelings
strategy matters I've never realized
that like it was like it's matters the
most like Fitness like that you want to
hear my fitness story real quick show
key Paula bond yeah on a plane five
years ago I realized everything good in
my life was when I was accountable to
others not myself mmm I'm a great boss
because I want to deliver for them not
what they do for me right I'm a good at
my content like I'm a give and I get
self
out of the selfishness selflessness of
it mm-hmm on this plane I realized right
I don't want to do more push-ups than I
did yesterday
I don't compete with myself like a lot
of people do and I don't do it for me so
I realized what if this is literally how
it went down what if I hired a full-time
person who travels with me because I'm
traveling a lot yeah and what if I
didn't want to let them down right
literally that's what's happened I
figured out my fitness life because I
don't want to let Mike or now Jordan and
that Mike's coming back for a tour and
I'm gonna switch on and off like I don't
want to let them down I love that and
that is like weird right like let me
hope to be that but it took strategy it
works for you yeah it's it's being
accountable to every it's why I'm
winning I'm accountable to everybody
else not my own selfish needs so many
people say to me like how how do I get
into working out and I say well you know
obviously if you can do stuff at home
but if you really want to do something
and be accountable and actually get it
done book a workout with a friend
because if you don't show up you've left
yeah I think people like that olive I'll
tell you one thing the other thing I've
been thinking a lot about about this
advice while we've been like talking
about other things if you make that
right hook back to January 8th of
Hannah's book coming out which is
strategic by HarperCollins is like these
are books over indexed during this time
I do believe though Hannah's right
always the right time to do the right
thing
but if we're talking business now back
to strategy I do believe that if you did
something where the opening for whatever
service you want to sell goes from
December 15th to January 15th you're
gonna get two bites at the Apple in
December 15th people are festive people
get their bonuses people like are in a
buying spirit so you'll convert an
audience and on January 7th 8th 9th 10th
11th 12th people start dwelling and
start worrying that they haven't kicked
themselves into gear right I think if
you created that month that you liked
and stayed consistent did it every year
you're making a promise to the audience
that I'm never gonna try to monetize you
except for this window you'll see some
results from that as well I agree I love
it cool good luck bye
Gary bye Hannah thank you so much
pump for olive she got through let's get
one more in before we get this go like
you can set it up but what do we want to
cover before we get him one more call
and wrapped us up today what else should
people who are watching you know for
example tons of entrepreneurs probably
75% mail too so like let's you know
obviously one of the things I was you
know I don't have a lot of people on a
second time it means I like you yeah I
wanted to have you on because I know
you're I know enough about you in
culture that you're gonna crush your
audience you're gonna be on other
podcast shows TV whatever I was excited
because I think your message really
matters to you know to a lot of my
audience yeah and I don't honestly think
Rick in Iowa 23 year old cliche digital
marketers gonna go run out and pick up
your book if he's not watching right now
but I think he should yeah so I mean you
know this book really is geared for
everyone look like wanting to learn more
about themselves and I give my personal
anecdotes that kind of really affected
me and what made me want to affect
change within my lifestyle in addition
to kind of those philosophies and kind
of expert advice from a lot of people
who I've met over the years who I
constantly rely on there's a ton of
delicious recipes in there that anyone
can make and there's just like you know
it's just good knowledge also on how
your body works we're in this world does
you're extremely handsome husband live
his life um so my husband is like kind
of for like almost the same person we're
very he's very healthy as well I mean he
give up helping do you actually in a
macro think you guys are super similar
we I do so I have a very interesting
thesis about this oh it's scary it means
that you really love yourself
interesting well I think that about me
my wife and I have a lot of similarities
and I think it means that I love myself
you know like like I do think that like
there's a really interesting insight
that you decided to spend your whole
life with somebody that it's just like
me yeah I guess that's kind of there's a
self only thing there that I'm trying to
figure out we're also both Scorpios I am
as well oh you are too birthday October
26 oh you're in October Scorpio
I'm kidding I'm kidding I knew you guys
would love that I'm kidding I'm kidding
I knew that would deliver on November
14th oh you're the 14 my cousin's the
14th Brendan's November 3rd um but
honestly you know he it's funny a real
good team I need a t-shirt I need it now
I'm being serious custom t-shirt Oh dot
dot dot dot
you're an October Scorpio I want to rock
that okay well I when you see me near
Port rockin that recall this podcast
people always people do say that to me a
lot they're like oh you're a baby
Scorpio and I'm Michael don't forget
that baby scorpions have a bigger sting
really just FYI but I was gonna say also
about branch thing October's not as cool
and about that's way cooler also a
scorpion coming out love it okay I
really do gravitate towards November
people I really do be in Scorpio - you
mean with more videos yeah you're right
cuz what are they after
what's on the back of Scorpio
Sagittarius you're sad do you hook the
[ __ ] everything was going so well real
quick now I'm really interrupted but I
have to deliberate okay tell me
soft-tissue where do you sit if at all
on soft tissue work do you know what I'm
talking about your fossa yes yeah it's
super important you got a massage that
work it out it's like you know it's the
be your biggest organ you know they're
laughing because this is like my number
like while we're I don't know if you
were noticing I just found a nice you
gotta look this is your area of like
deep expertise or like like I believe so
me mm-hmm I will tell you that I have
had a bad back cuz I've worked in my
dad's liquor store when I was a kid
mm-hmm my whole life mm-hmm it is little
it's changed your life doing soft did
you work no no no no what like really
changed my life yeah I think it's a
conspiracy I think the entire
chiropractor like massage industry is
suppressing the soft tissue industry
because I'm completely nutter Lee
convinced so on fascial like you would
not believe so facha work is really
really important and also your lymph
your hold'em Phatak system lies in your
soft tissue and so like a lymphatic
massage is very soft but it's engaging
the way you the way you get rid of
toxins out of your body the amount of
talks
that I've gotten out of my body in the
last 36 months that is completely and I
mean from a quality day-to-day life
perspective do you see a difference in
like the quality of your legs no no you
look up everywhere like no like I'm
lucid I can't
I every time I get a chance to sell this
I do cuz it's because the happiness that
I have that I discovered this my quality
of life is so much greater like it was
real restrictive pain like it restricts
your motion you know delay and you don't
need to know so water retention really
lies within the soft tissue I didn't
know that since I drink no water number
two we'll have to address that number
two you're talking somebody who works
out seven days a week what does that
mean four to five days real two days you
know we do soft tissue work like I will
roll yeah and like and like hardcore so
I get that lactic for us in an hour
yeah not two minutes like I see other
people right they'll do it for 2-3
minutes and then they work out minimum
I'll roll for 15 to 20 minutes a day by
the way that I think that's gonna be one
of the largest trends in 2019 within the
wellness world is recovery and soft
tissue work so it's so funny I think
that we should start a business because
I think you have a great brand I
literally want to start I think like the
way rumbles crushed it and soul cycle
and like all the trends
I'm not kidding and the funny thing is I
think people would be blown away because
think about how lazy everyone is imagine
a place where you walk in and you do
nothing so there's a place in Flatiron
that's like all about stretching I know
about that yeah I'm walking think yeah
yeah I'm talking fashion work yeah soft
tissue work which by the way hurts like
[ __ ] like I'm like like Teeter yeah
and I'm good with pain tolerance but
like literally just no no I'm telling so
you're saying like you know if your
shits really [ __ ] up like mine is it's
literally to the touch right and let me
just explain how crazy soft tissue work
is I've been doing it now for two and a
half years everyday and four days ago
I realized how [ __ ] up my front what
is this your quad my front quad is
literally means like I was like cured
and there's something and I was like
trying it and like finally and like God
in there but I'm like it's like right
here
like it was like my first thing was the
abductor yeah which I mean guys
soft-tissue fashio I can't I'm telling
you it's the one that 90% of people that
get massages and chiropractor this and
my [ __ ] disk that like neck work like
I'm like like I'm trying to like figure
out the fash on my eye pockets like I'm
all over this
totally I actually had to work out my
quads yesterday because my calves were
so tight and like your calves are
connected to the quads and so I didn't
even focus on my quads even though that
was where the majority of the pain and
tightness coming from it's all coming
for my quads one last one
I'm really into this one because it's I
think it's for the normal person the
thing that's really bothering them in
their lives people have headaches
because their neck it's literally just
your shoulder and sometimes it's your
rib cage
I mean I'm telling you mhm been Gary Vee
how are you good sir I'm tremendous
please say hello to Hannah hi hello
Hannah
hello Hannah how are you I'm great
thanks how are you I'm doing awesome
some great to talk to you guys well love
your content Gary and and Hannah first
question do you have this book available
in audio format I do
absolutely did you rate it I only read I
was only read my intro I actually tried
to read the whole book but it wasn't in
my contract that I signed two years ago
I'm looking at my publisher right now
but I did try to read it myself but they
said no ma'am Oh interesting yeah all
right is that you guys decided
professional would do better like that's
okay like I think that's right I'm like
I'm not Michelle Obama you know and I
mean I guess that's what they were
thinking do what you do best and I
what's the rest look I'll tell you my
bad singular most hated thing
professionally that I do is read my own
book for audio I have to do it because I
have to do it your thought that my book
would not be me reading it no your voice
is like it's a synonymous with your
brand
plus I improv the whole way but I'm
terrible
I've actually you don't even put you're
not like not reading like you're yeah I
go create like look you should see the
people like when I'm in a recording
studio they're like you know straight
men and women they're used to like
everybody being professional yeah I mean
like second sentence I'm like
actually you know what I changed my mind
and you can see their head pop up and be
like even though they were warned by the
publisher because I've done five of them
they're like he'll probably go
off-script
I go off the reservation I think that
would be a YouTube goal to watch you in
a studio form but you know what Ben I
know what's funny is it's real torture
for me because I would I often say one
of the things I do I'm really not a good
reader
I've actually genuinely believed I've
become a better reader out of the sheer
pressure of having to read my book in
audiobook form it actually did teach me
learning patterns of like reading ahead
like things like yes I'm not really um
Ben are you an audiobook consumer only
uh not not only but it helps because
like you know I'm on the road a lot I'm
just constantly here there and
everywhere and I feel that I understand
it better when I hear it and do you that
is just this is now flowing from my own
fun because I think I'm interested do
you feel like you're even leaning more
into audiobooks because of the way
podcasts and other things have happened
in culture no I have ADHD in an eighth
grade education and reading was one of
the things that I really really
struggled with and that's the honest
truth
so yeah hearing it's a lot better I
learned by seeing things yeah man but
reaping it was it's just tough yeah the
other question I had for for you was how
did people from your past lifestyle you
said you did you know the nightlife
thing for a couple years I played in
bands for years and I got out of that
and you changed change the script
flipped it up yeah how did how did your
friends and your family react to that
and and how have they taken to the book
um so in the beginning it's funny
because when I started kind of posting I
was kind of already on the journey but I
wasn't necessarily talking about it with
where do you first start talking about
it cuz it's a wild so it was on
Instagram early and I guess in early
2012 and I was kind of showcasing my
like healthy habits and different
recipes and what I was doing at the gym
and I was using this hashtag which is
now the name of my company HP fit and I
realized that when I was going out at
night some of my friends were
eh be fit and they were asking me like
what did I do in the gym that day and I
just realized that this conversation
completely was changing and so once I
kind of realize that my even just my
friends were responding to the type of
content I was putting out that I wanted
to create a place where we could talk
about these things in longer form
content I think my family was super
excited just because I kind of grew up
in a really active home and my mom is
like a vegetarian Reiki Master like
crystal lover you know what I mean so
she was mom crystal down Oh crystal out
she used to tape crystals to her chakra
her to all her chakras and then like
answer the door for the FedEx guy and
I'd be like oh my god mom like crystal
culture is intense it's really intense I
mean she's like as a chanter she used to
study with a Kahuna like the whole thing
so yes I mean Bonnie no I was about to
laugh at myself it's funny what I think
is wild like crystals but I think you
should be a monk like like you know like
funny not like people pick and she it's
like that dude that called first he's
like yo I'm super healthy gallon water
but I eat Taco Bell right you know
exactly picking shoes so I think my mom
was the your mom was a head-on Oh
totally totally she's been like that
since like the 70s and so I think she
was really excited about me kind of
going down that journey and kind of
exploring that for myself and then there
were definitely people who kind of
didn't get it and thought it was all
[ __ ] and you trying to be good yeah
it's great goosey yeah totally and like
drink your tequila and like you know get
blackout like we know you used to right
type of thing you're not black out from
actually used to be called Bogart
Bronfman if you really want to know so
yeah so there were you know there were
believers and they were haters and like
everything in between but I kind of just
stuck down my path and and now like
people it's so funny like putting out a
book some people have come out of the
woodwork to tell me how proud they are
of me and I haven't even heard from
these people in so long and to be honest
the you know just the the reaction I'm
getting from the book from my
fans and followers has been so
meaningful and having these meetups
where I get to like sign people's books
and people within where'd you do your
Tuesday last week I did I did on
Wednesday and I did at this place called
bomb bury in in on Bleecker Street and I
think we had like 150 people come and
the signing took almost two hours
well I gave everyone that came in it I
don't have to like chat with it and
people really told me like insane
stories like about abusive relationships
and getting over lymphoma like it was
just it was really intense and I and
they were telling me about the part that
I played for them in their journey and
it's just it's been like yo do you know
time we blacked out in the club no no
not yet not yet but I'm sure if you were
one of those people reach out there
challenge on Instagram you know people
are doing oh yeah yeah and the photo I'm
gonna use spoiler alert is literally me
at the Jane in 2009 DJ with half of my
head shaved in a cigarette in one hand
so like and as your next post gonna be
an egg after that no what the hell's
going on with this damn egg hey what's
going on and we were just saying before
you got here it's like there's this
really fun moment going around on
Instagram literally two massive memes
like Instagram has been super quiet very
like early Twitter have these things
happen all the time we're like everybody
would get on board on something like
Twitter's not been like that at all and
then literally the tenure challenge and
the egg have happened literally within
24 hours of each other you say which I
actually think may be a pretty OB if
there's a third one that drops this week
it's gonna be like get ready for like a
year or two of like just everybody
trying to create these things on
Instagram which will probably ruin
Instagram and lead it to become MySpace
right which one herbal yes man who knows
we'll be over I didn't want to trip
what's the last thing I just want to say
is can I have a very small thing in
common you're going to talk about about
health and wellness
I want a thick book about its
publication mommy does CrossFit but mine
is slightly different than your Klout
really giving advice like yours
discourses far more better and superior
so I look forward to downloading yours
because I just think it's gonna be
awesome
oh well thank you so much I have a gray
hair thank you take care what is funny
yeah that was awesome awesome
I want to buy a hundred copies so have
you reached out to me I'm gonna put them
in the lobby of vaynermedia so that
people can wrap it and uh thanks for
being a show thank you so much this is
awesome
bye everyone later
[Music]